so passed the life for now that he
is
still identical in the sweet
uniformity of secrets
called with years
a deep trace his little
routine to preserve by all - in only the house to sorrow and have experienced the uselessness of the shelled dare  a mire
jean it was not to resign to
respect him
but even in the village three shots
from us the value before more and his
boxes
I asked Françoise if now
not to rest this train train of
yet troubled once this  year there
when free cash and it would not have come to
majority are not seen that this and comes
off and responsible for 20 nights the
bible said free years the
kitchen girl but it is an hour and d
internet the spans as it  there was
no midwife understood
françoise from the party before the day we are
looking for erin to release without my aunt
because of the cries of the kitchen girl could
not real buzz and and françoise despite the
short distance the derivatives we only
very  your  rd misses him very much too my
my mother tells me model in the morning
counts so see if to wait didn't
need anything i entered the
first room and speaks open doors
and my aunt cauchy on the mortgage who was
sleeping i  hear him say swell
slightly I was going to go away slowly
but no doubt resumed that I had done
had intervened in his sleep and we
had changed the speed ordered for
the cars only to the music of
snoring holy cheat for a second and
takes her and resumes a lower tone then
a sevilla and turning admitted her
use i could see then voice her some
kind of mistake
she obviously just had an
awful schedule and can you see me
the way
moved and I stood there not knowing if
I should move forward or murderer but
already she seemed warned to the
feelings of reality and with recognized
the lie of the visions that there would arrive
a smile of joy from the stones
gratitude towards god who allows  and
may life be me for her cruel than
drm and weakly clara her face
and with this habit that she loves with
grip of talking to herself in an undertone even
when she thought she was alone she will
have eyes either naked and  put in a man
as much of a hassle as it is in the kitchen
giving birth here it is not that I dreamed
that my poor late and was resurrected and
who wants to take you for a
walk every day it has me this time
various rosaries which were on the
small  table
but the summit begins we do
n't let them have the strength to wait for it wait for it for
no other she wonders or
reassure us and I sneak out
of the room are that blood nor
anyone has ever had  learned
i had heard when i say com2art
very rare event when this action
my aunt's train train never undergo had
any variations i'm not talking about the
ones that would be maybe always
identical at regular intervals
of a single trio  the user is a  e
kind of secondary uniformity
that's how all the trustees years old
françoise the names of the afternoon a
walk and run in town
the bread lunch was for everyone
an hour earlier they were waiting for me so
well took the  habit of this
weekly derogation from her habits that she
dedicated this habit there as much as to the
others and I was so screwed up
and as Françoise said if reading them to
my fans had a Saturday waiting for
their usual lunch that said as much to
disturb as  if she had had to in other
days before those surveyed general
hours of Saturday
this lunch announcement
given elsewhere or Saturday for all of us a
particular figurine indulgence is
quite nice
at the time when usually we still have an
hour to live before  prep relaxation
we knew that in a few seconds
we were going to see early endives arrive
a favor omelette a
steak email of merit and the network this
Saturday is symmetrical was one of those
pe  tits local domestic events
almost civil which in the
quiet ebit and closed societies
cries a kind becomes national and
becomes the topic and becomes the damany
part of the conversations
jokes stories exaggerated at
pleasure it would have been to drown all ready
for a legendary cycle  if one of us
had seen the head and pick from the morning
Germans to be dressed for no reason
for the pleasure experienced the france of
solidarity in said to each
other with a with good humor with
courtesy a cordiality with patriotism
he  there's no time to put
let's not forget that it's Saturday
however this while my aunt
cooperating with françoise and thinking that
the day would be longer
than usual was saying if you see them
good pieces of veal like this  saturday 6
at 10.30 am distracted yann took out her
watch saying on the news another dvi an
hour and a half
lunch everyone and in each camp
was delighted to have to tell him but
voyo  ns what are you thinking you forget
that these 110 we still laugh about it a quarter
of an hour later and we promised
ourselves asking to tell this forgetting waiting for the music the faces of 6mm are exchanged after lunch the
sun aware that his drawings  to
stroll there an hour higher from the sky
and as someone thinks that we
were late for the walk of the elders
as in only two hours
by seeing the two wheels of the
bell tower of saint clair pass by that they have
the  usual of our meeting and still
no one in the summer
patterns hardly any noon or siesta
london is very good it is good that the
fisherman even to give up and pass under
the ter in the sky goes that we only remain
a few  clouds paris this everyone was
still answering him but what's
fooling you is that we have young people is
an hour earlier or do you know that this
Saturday the surprise of a barbarian
we call all the people who did
n't know  that's what the
parties had  ulars on Saturday who had come at
11 a.m. to speak to my father
had found us at the table was one of the
things that in his life he had more and
win Françoise but if she found it
amusing that the visitors taken
aback was not that we had lunch rather the
Saturday
she found more concludes corinne
still a whole sympathizer of the
left front with sochaux nice but three
like my father him did not have the idea of
e by could ignore him he answered wi
hout further explanation is to his internment
o see us already  in the
dining room
but let's see it's Saturday having reached this
point in her story comes from
rurality for and to increase the
pleasure she feels and she
prolonged the invented dialogue what
the visitor had replied to that this
Saturday n  explain nothing is far
from complaining about these additions it
was not enough yet and we were saying it it
seemed to me that he had also said
something else it was longer the first
time he left  e the meadow see as
you have told my great aunt
herself about her driver the head
there are parts hickeys doriot health
still had this particularity that that
day during the month of May we
went out after dinner to go to the
month of march like us they
sometimes meet mr venteuil very severe
for the deplorable kind of young people
neglected in the ideas of the
current time my mother take care
nothing is wrong adam maintained powerful
party police
it is a month of mary that i am
remember having started to like the
hawthorns is therefore not only in
the church 6 1 but we had the
entrance fee posed on the water of itself
inseparable from mystery in the celebration of
which she took part she
physically
the middle days of the flames high
and low rhinois branch attached or
horizontally to each other in
after the fact is that they put away had in
play still releases the festoons of their
journey which is decimated at p  rofusion
as if a vitry bride train
from the button of their glowing
they are tidy watching them that
stealthily I felt that it is after mende
pompous and living excite nature
itself which in the presence of cultures
in facts in  purchasing their
supreme moment of these white sheep had
made this decoration worthy of those who
were at once a
popular rejoicing a single mystical unity
grossopens and their corollas here and there
with a race associating it treatment
cite clearly how last and the
word around the  bouquet of ladies in
fine like threads of honey like
what was beer that it is between my
doubts in its entirety that by following
that they are trying to put me deep inside me
the gesture their adolescence I myself  imagined
that if it had been the
cock-eyed and diminished cottonwoods rapid head and toes movement
of a white
girl distracted on Sunday on the internet
came with her daughter to stand next to
my  from a good family he had been the
teacher
of the sisters the grandmother and when after
the death of his wife and the inheritance he
had paid he had retired to
combre very often at home
but with excessive prudishness he
tries to come so as not to meet
care who had what he called
leading in arial move in the taste of the
day
my mother is a price he was dialing
had told him by skill that when you are
when they would go to see him  it takes what
made him hear something of him
sir 9 p.m. we would have had a lot
of joy but push and push and the
politeness and the lame quentin
scruples that those always putting in the
place of others
he took 2 the springs and to
appear it  selfish he only let
his desire become the days when my
parents were and to go to his house to
visit
I had accompanied them he had
allowed me to stay outside
and like the house when the house of
sir built me I  sell and go there
below a mound but is called where
I put pills I found myself on the same
level as the second floor living
room 50 cm from the window when we
came to tell him my parents I saw
sir vannetaise said to
highlight the piano a piece of music
once mute but not returned they
had been done and put in a corner
no doubt had said the crash of the erc
suggest he was happy
to see them that
his compositions for them and each time my
mother came back to the charge
during the visit he repeated several times
but I don't know who put that on the
piano it's not his place and had
diverted the condensation those of  other
subjects precisely because
that interested him month his only passion was
for his daughter and this one who
looked like a boy because so robust
that one could not help smiling
when seeing the clean ones and when  these
precautions that her father dragged for
her there are always  additional young bear
to him thrown on the
shoulders
my grandmother remarked that
the soft delicate almost
shy expression often given past in the
look of this child so rough in the
face in the visual of the strewn
with bloodstains when she came  to say
a word she heard with the spirit
of those to whom she had told sarah to come
from the least sick possible d owen and
we saw that the woman cut herself out
as if by transparency on the hard life on
the steps of the world is very more
fine who you useful purposes i cried